[Musique]
c'est l'horreur
le moindre bruit venant de là-haut me
donne la nausée
si vous faites descendre
vous ne serez plus obligé de vivre cet
enfer
second lieutenant reilly monsieur quel
est le but de votre visite un ancien
camarade et sur le front le capitaine
stanhope je vous déconseille de vous
joindre à eux
nous nous attendons à une offensive de
taille j'y tiens monsieur je vous
présente monsieur riley ils viennent
rejoindre la compagnie
le dîner servi du me demande ce que vous
nous avez encore préparés comme festin
mes [ __ ] c'est une bonne question
serait bien incapable de vous le dire
ckrl en allant faire notre officier
supérieur
vous le connaissez oh oui bien sûr vous
risquez de le trouver changée
il a connu des moments difficiles avec
cette compagnie mason apporter du risque
et bonjour stand up
elle vous attend j'ai aucune envie
qu'elle me voit dans cet état l'averse
avait dit rien à signaler par contre la
rouge sert à donner l alerte
je dirais la mauvaise une fois
ça a bien failli nous coûter la guerre
le déserteur allemand de la compagnie
des prétend que l'attak aura lieu le 21
un prg m
j'ai pas aimé abricots
[Musique]
je vais pas tenir
vous pensez qu'il ya une limite à ce que
je peux endurer je suis navré si je vous
ai fâché hommes joignant cette compagnie
est sévère
j'ai peur je ressens exactement la même
chose
ils ressemblent tous la même chose que
nous
mais ils continuent malgré tout c'est
tout ce que peut faire un homme digne de
stands
[Musique]
j'ai bien l'intention de survivants
pas vous
[Musique]